-Drew, welcome to the show.
Come on.
Can you be cooler?
There's no cool like you.
-I can't believe nobody's
worn this sweatshirt
all this time.
No one rocks it like you.
I mean, look at the shoes,
everything.
You know how to do it.
Come on, bud.
-Shoe, pink lip.
-The pink lip.
You know the deal.
I got to say, you know, I watch
your show every single day.
I love it.
Congrats on that.
"The Drew Barrymore Show"
is awesome, and I -- It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I love it, I love --
There's so many things about it
I love, but it was your birthday
the other day. Happy belated.
-Thank you -- 2/22/22.
-Two two two two two two two.
-It's so crazy.
I --
I mean, like,
I was born in '75 --
1975.
-Yeah, of course.
-And you just don't even think
about that future date.
Like, it's --
it's almost a surreal thing.
-Yeah.
-Like the year 2000 seemed nuts.
Remember, we were all going
to party like it's 1999.
It just, you know --
-Yeah, Y2K, man.
-I never thought I'd get here,
and I've been looking so forward
to that auspicious number
of a day
that we'll kind of only see
once in our lifetime.
-But then you actually
were hosting your show
on your birthday?
-I was!
Which is so happy because I got
to wake up with the kids,
and then I got to go to work and
our job, our work environment --
you guys know it's a family.
It's positive.
It's like the rest of, you know,
your problems
kind of dissipate and fade away
when you go to work
because we're all working
on something so positive
and multifaceted
and that feed our souls.
And then I got to go home
after work, and I walked in,
and there was a blindfold
taped to the door and --
My daughters had put up there.
-Okay.
Thank you for clearing that up.
[ Laughter ]
-And I put it on, and I'm led in
by my daughters,
and Olive learned to play
"Happy Birthday"
for me on the piano.
She's in lessons, but she taught
herself by herself.
-Come on.
-And then Frankie --
And they got me
a Fudgie the Whale cake.
-Carvel!
Fudgie the Whale's the best!
-It's the greatest!
-It's the greatest cake.
-And they made me
beaded necklaces.
And then our dog, Lucy --
And, you know, Gary and Lucy
are, like, twinning.
And -- And then
Lucy jumped on the cake
and started eating
the whole thing.
And dogs cannot have chocolate.
-Of course.
-So within a matter
of just a minute,
the whole place looked nuts.
-Chaos.
-And I was like, "This is
the best birthday ever."
-Yeah, of course, dude!
That's the best. Why not?
-That's it.
-I was watching your show
because I was like,
they were celebrating you
on your show,
and then you got a surprise
from The Go-Go's,
and they came on.
They Zoomed on together,
and they gave you this.
They made you an honorary Go-Go.
-I mean, that's me.
-That's Drew.
They -- They --
-I mean --
-They made this for me,
and because I went
and I inducted them
into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame.
Here's -- I have
a photo of that, by the way.
This is you doing --
This was genius.
You did this
as you were intro'ing them.
You started putting on,
you know, a night mask,
whatever,
a towel over your head.
It felt sort of like, "Okay.
These are the women that,
when they came into my life,
when I was about 6 years old,
they told me,
'You can do anything you want.
You can --'"
I mean, Nan and I made
"Charlie's Angels."
I don't think I would have dared
make a "Charlie's Angels"
if it wasn't for The Go-Go's.
And what I loved is,
they didn't say,
"You have to pretend
to be a man."
You get to be
with your girlfriends
and do everything you dream.
And it was the best sort of
tone-setter for my entire life.
So I was like, "How do I pay
these women in the right way?"
And I just thought,
"I'm gonna go back to
when I was a little girl,
saw that album cover,
and it changed my life forever,"
and I put the mask on.
-It was the best moment of the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
-Oh, my God! Thank you!
I was so nervous.
-Questlove was there,
and I got a text from him,
he said, "Yo, your girl
is crushing it right now."
-I'm so relieved.
-And I was like, "What?
What is she doing?" He's like,
"Just wait till you see.
She's intro'ing The Go-Go's,
and it's brilliant."
-Oh, my God,
I felt so much pressure
to get that moment right.
How do you say to someone
or a group of people,
"My life changed
because of you"?
And the whole trajectory,
I know,
ties back to seeing these girls
that just --
There was
such a wow factor to me.
It was like The Go-Go's
and Pippi Longstocking
are my DNA.
[ Laughter ]
-Pippi Longstocking, of course.
-Of course.
Girls who were girls
who can do anything.
I told you already this,
but I loved your interview
with Donny Osmond.
I thought it was awesome.
I love Donny Osmond. I was like,
"Dude, it was great."
You were just great
and asked some great questions.
That's the part of your show
that I love the best
because you ask questions,
they're like...
A lot of the times,
they're like,
"That's the best question.
No one's ever asked me that."
-Thank you.
-And I love that you do that.
Yeah, I love it.
-I was freaked out
for your interview
with Dua last night.
-That was.
-That's my pal.
-That was a breakdown
of humanity and experience
and "These are the things
I've learned,
and this is how I've grown."
It was so informative.
-Dua Lipeeps.
-I already am, like,
psychotically obsessed with her,
and now I'm like,
"Oh, no. How --"
-She's actually cooler
than you even understand.
-It hurts.
-It actually hurts.
-But it was great to hear her
talk about real stuff.
-Yeah.
-You know?
That's what we want to do --
we want to have fun
and lean into comedy,
but I need to get real
every once in a while
because it's not all...
-That's why people love you.
-Oh. God.
-Yeah, because, no, it's good.
You get -- You get emotional.
You're not afraid
to do any of that stuff.
-I -- I know our tone
of the show is weird,
but I'm weird,
and I -- I like comedy.
It's medicine to me.
I like news.
I like, you know, food
and design and human interest
and conversations
and seeing somebody
you've loved your whole life
walk out and be like,
"Oh, my God," and someone
you had never met before,
but you will always remember
them after hearing their story.
Everybody has a story.
-Everyone's got a story, yeah.
And I want to talk more.
-Okay!
-More with Drew Barrymore
when we come back.